this is the i'm con continuously
perplexed
to hear the stories that i do what guys
do
because i'm just i'm just living in this
world thinking guys don't do that
no guys that i know do stuff like this
do you know what i mean yeah they don't
do that yeah
yeah and i'm just constantly being let
down
they're letting the team down because
i'm just hearing yes they do these guys
that you think are so cool they're not
they're creeps
did you hear about the um that actor um
army hammer is that his name the guy
he is so you know from the social
network movie yes
you know the winklevoss twins no
i don't remember twitter okay so um
he's only seen it once all right so in
the social network movie there was
obviously two twins there were roman
champions
okay that at harvard okay yeah i
remember that bit yeah yeah so it's the
same guy that plays both of them
okay and he was also in the movie the
man from uncle
i've not seen that movie but i know of
the movie yeah so henry
henry cavill and him he's the other one
okay yeah so
that guy that actually is a googly face
yeah i need his googly space
he apparently there's this like
conspiracy at the minute that he sent
out um
messages to oh my you know my man
oh okay okay yeah continue here yeah
yeah yeah he sent out messages to all
these girls on instagram okay
talking about the sexual [ __ ] he wants
to do
okay and then he goes in there saying i
want like
he's talking [ __ ] fam like i want to eat
you
like i want to cut off your legs
barbecue them up i want
like fab he's getting nasty with it like
real
cannibal [ __ ] oh my real dark cannibal
[ __ ] i can't remember the exact
phrasings
yeah yeah real dark camel [ __ ] and it's
not one girl's come out and say it like
five six girls have come out and said it
obviously mine's not nah nah nah nah nah
nah nah nah that's wild that's not me of
course it's not me yeah that's not me
um but apparently his ex-wife
come out or ex-girlfriend's wife i can't
remember like made it like a brief
statement i was just like
he said
like he said he's just like just like
trust me like
it's between you off the record from
after echoes
when he gets hard on he says some [ __ ]
he's crazy
yeah fam apparently she came out and was
like
i'm not saying it is or it isn't yeah
but it wouldn't surprise me
oh the [ __ ] that comes out this guy's
mouth wouldn't surprise me
that's when everything's up in the air
now everything's open now fam yeah and
apparently he turned down
a movie role that he was supposed to do
okay and people are saying like he's
saying like
oh while you're putting me and my family
through all this like um
i think it was like universal or
whatever they were doing the production
they're like they stand with me
and they understand why i'm like uh
turning down this position for the time
being or postponing this position
and all this stuff like he was supposed
to start on his movie or whatever and
then people are coming up and um
being like some people oh yeah that
makes sense it probably wasn't him
but then other people coming out like in
the industry coming out like
big man do you think that
universal studios are gonna close a
movie
because he's getting weird accusations
about instagram dms
come on come on he got sacked of course
he goes it was him and he got
he got sacked even if it wasn't him they
would have sacked him anyway
we're not dealing with this we're just
going to replace you yeah we're dealing
with everybody you're sacked
for the fact that you don't know his
name you're nobody to us you know what i
mean
we can do we're universal we can do we
want we can do what we can get who we
want for this we'll get a black guy free
so no one will say anything
family is probably best if we do we need
the balance right now you're
you're helping us out if anything we've
got enough [ __ ] weird white blonde
guys
as leads
man said he wants the barbie cops on the
legs family he said he wants to do some
[ __ ] certain man get
kicks from different things man some
people aren't normal
oh bro some people are not normal porn
just isn't it for them
they want a next thing they want a level
up a level two up
for unverified messages we've busted
across this reporter showing hammer
chatting with several women in explicit
conversations playing his fetishes
where he allegedly expresses his sexual
appetite to drink blood
cut toes and enslave his sex partners
the messages allegedly sent by hammer
describe rape fantasies
one of hammer's exes told a tabloid the
actor wanted to barbecue
and eat her ribs another ex said
immediately that he carved his initial
into her skin
on her pelvis engaging in knife play
oh my god bro
oh my god bro drinking
blood fam some people i don't know where
they get these fetishes
but i was thinking the other day imagine
being imagine being him
and knowing that like this is what turns
me on yeah normal [ __ ] doesn't cut it
though
she doesn't cut me and these men are
coming after me like i'm the animal i'm
the victim
you think i don't just want to watch
missionary porn you think i don't just
want to bash
i'm not you don't want to just think i
just want to [ __ ] like normal family i
can't
it doesn't do it for me i want to eat
you
inside out for him i want to [ __ ] you
literally i'm going to kill you and eat
you
that's what will get me hard batman then
i want to [ __ ] your corpse oh my god
that's what it is for me
i don't like jesus this life chose me
you might need to feel sorry for me and
i'm getting sacked
because i'm just trying to find out
who's down
i'm just trying to find out who's that
he's down it can't just be me
it can't oh some man have weird fetishes
fam i know it's dread because the only
guy
the only person he's going to find out
that's down there's another guy of
course
he's always the other guy on craigslist
let's just be like i'll do it
of course eat me eat me up